mike fires one previous start against
the padres way back a long time ago but
dallas detail he's been pitching
extremely well
his last three starts in which he's
picked up victories but i think the most
important thing he's gone in those
starts six innings five in the third
sixth innings and the a's need to get
some links out of the starter 94 degrees
we are
finding out now
according to the records this is the
warmest
game in coliseum history
to the wall it makes the catch so
when we say it's hot
it's a record hop
so here's hosper the designated hitter
strike three called on the inside corner
well hosmer not happy about it and the
a's get the call here on a fastball that
looked like it started to work its way
back over the inside part but shawn
murphy doing a good job of dressing it
up back there scared richards ready for
his ninth start of the year we take a
look at the 32 year old right hander his
ninth start as you mentioned and no
nibbling he's got to go on the attack
stella 264 loriano hitting second a
little flare that's gonna work and then
it kicks past profar la stella is going
to end up going to second base
lead off at it for the ace
stella
just gonna
shoot a flare out to left the stella
anchored a second and that'll bring up
matt olson that's gonna be a base in
right field here comes la stella la
stella will score without a throw in the
a's jump out ahead one nothing a big two
out hit for matt olson has been on base
in 20 of the last 21 games
a base percentage of 407 during that
time current road trip though hitting at
241 he has cooled off a little bit
as he sends this one out towards left
center field and just as i say it gets
himself a base head loriano kicks it
literally to grossman the left fielder
and into second base goes cronenworth
he'll stand at second with two down they
have the shift on the infield and now
mike turns and here it is and that swung
on it popped up third base way might be
playable will be chapman back of the
coach's box he's there and he makes the
catch and fires works out of it just one
nothing is one out bottom of the second
and the padres play the infield for two
as murphy checks in
in the dirt gets away and trying to
score from third is growth from the
throat of the plate he is out
so richards covers
called him out but it looked like he may
have gotten in oakland is going to
challenge because typically when you get
that leg tucked under that front foot
comes up
you got to credit robbie grossman
getting in there with that foot on the
ground all right we got an answer he is
out
so the call stands on the field and
grossman can't believe it and quite
frankly either can we
first and third with one out and brings
up eric hosmer
line to right field and that's in for a
base head from third comes grisham he'll
score tatis will get to third it's an
rbi single for hosmer and the padres tie
the score one to one now manny machado
out of the cleanup spot only the fourth
time he's done that this year runners on
the corners one out he swings at the
first pitch lines it to left grossman
makes the catch tatis is tagging here
comes the throw it'll be cut off and a
sacrifice fly by manny machado gives the
padres their first lead of the day 2-1
san diego here in the third so two on
one out for matt olsen he's now 2-1 in
the third single did a run his last time
up let's hit hard toward first tough hop
scoots past moreland lustela's gonna
come home
he's gonna score all the way to third
goes kenneth
so the a's catch a break and a very hard
hit ball that popped right past
marlin
and it's a 2-2 game hazel take it a
hard-hit ball off the bout of matt olson
you can check it out here
right as it hits the dirt just kind of
kicks off to the right just a bit
which is all estella is going to need to
come around
and score safely and the lead off man
award for the padres for the very first
time this afternoon here is jake
cronenworth who has already doubled and
stolen a base for the very first time we
can finally say jake cronenworth is a
qualified hitter this one is hit well to
right field on the move is biscotti and
that's going to get down to the track of
the wall
from first base meyer's going to try and
score the go ahead run the throw coming
plateward and myers will be safe it's
cut off and the padres take a 3-2 lead
jake cronenworth with his second hit of
the day it's an extra base hit and the
padres take a 3-2 lead oh you got to
love the hitting and he is going gap
today left center in his first at-bat
right center here
that's a beautiful swing here's merv
trying to start something with two outs
a's trailing by three in the seventh hit
to left field
profile turning around and that baby's
gone way out of here
so murphy's third home run of the year
cuts into the padres lead a little bit
it's five to three
and the padres are not away from winning
this game taking the series two out of
three getting happy flight and coming on
home tonight in the air sent to right
center field over is grisham he'll make
the catch in front of the warning track
in the padres win
the padres hold on to a 5-3 victory and
take two out of three